good morning John it is the final day of
pizza myths and this year's pizzas
products are only available during these
weeks so if you want to be a part of it
if you want to get one of these things
your time is running out and what a
pizza miss it's been we've had left beef
good cats
let it snow premier you went to people's
house is your video yesterday was
helpful for me but a thing you said in
your video gave me an idea here's here's
the thing you said and I watch a lot of
YouTube not all of it nourishing which
is okay I think there is a place in this
world for wondrously empty distraction
now has is kind of obvious you and I
share a YouTube account which is not how
normal people use YouTube and to some
extent I think everybody is sometimes
confused by the decisions that the
YouTube algorithm makes some of this
makes sense there's always football
videos Tom Scott PBS eons but cleaning a
record with wood glue but when you share
an account sometimes you don't know when
YouTube is being weird versus when your
brother is being weird cuz suddenly
there's a lot of like vending machine
business videos in your recommended and
like why your John with the expectation
that you've been watching vending
machine videos I'm gonna take it to
camera two and we're gonna look through
the vlogbrothers channels YouTube
history for the last couple weeks I want
to know ah a lot of these are gonna be
mine I watched John's video I've been
watching all of chika she's amazing but
this one's John it's him watching his
own vice sports special not embarrassing
at all Johnny watch a lot of tetris
videos you watch a lot of football
manager videos that's gonna be standard
in beyond yellow scream that was not me
let's find out what that is it's like a
Bob Ross thing gonna put get a bunch of
yellow he's got a lot of yellow
well somebody's gonna have to explain
this in the comments we gotta go back
everyday days who are these people how
do you even know who they are and then
the sailing videos there's always
sailing videos of my recommendation you
don't like the water several different
people singing auld lang syne I'm gonna
guess that this is research for
something you're doing there it is first
one should I quit my vending machine
business I knew it I knew it and another
one and more and like more vending
machine all the way through and they're
all like 15 20 minutes long 1.3 million
views YouTube is so weird now I'm doing
the exact same faces doctor Benji FM
here how much does a laundromat cost to
run John I'm gonna support you whatever
direction you want to go in your life
but I do want to have a serious
conversation before you go start a
laundromat minutephysics football
football Rick and Morty is gonna be a
bunch of good place videos here yeah
that was me organ clop jörgen clop
advanced algorithm cops i-22 for lecture
1 from Harvard University John John you
watched Hank Maureen and John and Grand
Rapids our first event together 5
minutes long you watched that recently
that's very cute Wow I watched the
adventure zone season 3 trailer 2 times
and John watched Saffy and I guards
choosing my wedding dress and then Mike
Tyson hoverboard fail and fall John it's
a fascinating look into your psyche and
your day but let's go back to camera 1
pizza miss is ending there are many
different pizza in its products at
dftba.com that you can get now through
the end of the weekend and then never
again we got our pineapple no pineapple
pens and so far I would say pineapples
winning a lot though it may just be that
like no pineapple people are like yeah I
mean whatever live your life I don't
want to yuck on your warm salty fruit
all the shirts from our wonderful
designers only available until the end
of the weekend and all the profits from
pizza mousse products are going to
increase maternal health in Sierra Leone
John thank you for the wonderful pizza
miss I wish you all the luck in your new
vending machine business and I will see
you on normal Tuesday conspiracy theory
is the YouTube algorithm suggesting
vending machine videos because it wants
people to get used to the idea of
servicing machines